Sonic the Hedgehog is full of thrills, friendship,
and lots of high-speed action, but as it dashes
through its rapid-fire plot, it does stumble
on occasion.
Do the highs outweigh the lows?
Hold on tight as we run through the five best
and five worst things about Sonic the Hedgehog.
Sonic may be a quick moving blue alien who
can occasionally channel earth-shattering
bolts of electricity, but fortunately he's
got his good pal Tom Wachowski to keep him
grounded.
James Marsden does an excellent job balancing
out Sonic's hyperactive energy, approaching
the increasingly wild predicaments the two
of them find themselves in with a positive
attitude and a remarkably patient sense of
humor.
Filling in the roles of a classic buddy movie
team, Tom acts as the straight man to Sonic's
frenetic wise guy, but that doesn't mean that
Sonic gets all the laughs.
"Do you have your child in that bag?"
"No.
I mean yes, it's a child, but it's not mine."
Despite not having any kids of his own, Tom
can't help but radiate some major dad vibes,
thanks not in small part to some truly cringeworthy
puns.
At one point, when Sonic laments that he has
to leave Earth to go live on a planet made
up entirely of giant mushrooms, Tom quips,
"at least you won't be the only fun guy!"
Between his bad jokes, his tendency to play
out full conversations with his donuts, and
his fatherly protectiveness of Sonic, Tom
really is the best friend an alien hedgehog
could wish for, and he brings a refreshing,
nurturing energy to the film.
While Sonic the Hedgehog is at its best when
it's just letting Sonic and Tom hang out together
naturally, the film begins to show some signs
of strain whenever it leans into the conflict
between Tom and his sister-in-law, Rachel.
Although Tom and his wife Maddie are shown
to have a mutually supportive and loving relationship,
as soon as Maddie goes to visit Rachel and
her young daughter JoJo, it becomes clear
that Rachel flat-out hates Tom, even going
so far as to tell Maddie she thinks they should
get a divorce.
Later on, once Tom becomes a wanted fugitive,
it's a little more understandable why Rachel
doesn't want him in her house, but her animosity
toward him is established well before that.
Perhaps there's a deleted scene somewhere
explaining her open hostility toward Tom,
but her reasoning isn't even hinted at in
the finished film.
Considering that Tom is consistently portrayed
as the film's co-hero alongside Sonic, it
doesn't really make sense why Rachel is so
strongly opposed to him, and leads to conflict
that feels manufactured and forced.
Family can be messy, especially when it comes
to in-laws, but since Maddie and Rachel are
shown to have a good relationship with each
other, it feels strange that Rachel seems
to have declared war on her sister's husband
for no apparent reason.
Back in 2014, X-Men: Days of Future Past helped
moviegoing audiences realize the full comedic
potential in speedster characters when Quicksilver
zipped around a kitchen full of prison guards
as time -- from his perspective -- slowed
to a near standstill.
Jim Croce's dreamy "Time in a Bottle" played
under the scene, serving as an excellent auditory
illustration of Quicksilver's lazy perception
of time versus everyone else's perception
of Quicksilver.
Sonic has two scenes that riff on a similar
theme, when time seems to suddenly halt so
that Sonic can leisurely move around, repositioning
the people and objects around him to work
to his advantage.
The first takes place during a brawl during
the first half of the movie, and the second
during Sonic's penultimate showdown with Dr.
Robotnik.
Neither one is quite as satisfying as the
scene in X-Men, but they're both still a lot
of fun, and take great pleasure in showing
off just how awesome super speed can be.
After Tom reluctantly teams up with Sonic,
agreeing to drive the extraterrestrial hedgehog
to San Francisco because of Sonic's poor sense
of direction, they stop briefly for supplies
at a convenience store across from a bar.
Predictably, while Tom is off getting road
trip snacks, Sonic becomes curious about the
bar, and heads inside, donning a coat, a cap,
and a pair of sunglasses as a "disguise."
Tom tracks him down, and Sonic convinces him
to allow him to knock a few fun items off
his bucket list, since he plans to leave Earth
forever as soon as they reach San Francisco.
Unfortunately, after a fun montage of Sonic
and Tom line dancing, throwing darts, and
riding an electric bull, the two get targeted
by a group of local bullies who tell them
that they're not welcome in the bar, for a
surprising reason.
"We don't like your kind around here."
"What kind is that?"
“Hipsters."
The fight that breaks out following this challenge
feels a little random, but more concerning
is the way the film makes light of discrimintation.
It's a strange thing to make into a punchline,
and while the movie was likely trying to subvert
the obvious expectation that the bar patrons
are uncomfortable with Sonic because he's
a blue alien hedgehog, its attempt to equate
hipsters with marginalized communities falls
flat.
All that running can really take a toll on
a hedgehog's feet and footwear, and after
Sonic becomes injured, Maddie, a veterinarian,
discovers while examining him that he's worn
large holes in both his socks and his sad,
mismatched, taped-together shoes.
Of course, at the time Maddie notes the sorry
state of Sonic's footwear, she has a much
bigger concern, since Sonic is still unconscious
from an explosion after a close call with
Dr. Robotnik.
However, little JoJo, Maddie's young niece,
looks thoughtfully at Sonic's shoes, then
runs off to her room, making it easy to guess
her intent.
Sure enough, when Sonic wakes up and JoJo
returns, she presents him with a pair of bright
new red and white shoes.
While it's definitely satisfying to see Sonic
complete his video game look, it's even more
fulfilling to see a little girl show compassion
toward Sonic after he's spent the whole movie
desperately pining for friends.
It's clear from the beginning of the film
that Sonic's constant chatter and exuberant
nature belie a deep loneliness, as he laments
that the only way for him to protect himself
is for others to not know he exists.
In giving Sonic her shoes, JoJo not only fulfills
a practical need for him, but also an emotional
one -- she shows him that someone cares, and
that he's not alone.
Early on in Sonic the Hedgehog, after Dr.
Robotnik forces his way into Tom's home, he
has his drones open fire on Tom and Sonic,
utterly destroying Tom and Maddie's kitchen
and dining room.
As Sonic and Tom try to escape, Sonic observes
that the drones feel excessive, and he's right.
For much of the movie, the conflict feels
off balance, as though it belongs in a much
more grandiose film.
Yes, it's a film about an electrically charged
alien hedgehog running very, very fast, but
even so, all Sonic and Tom are trying to do
throughout the entire film is get to San Francisco
so they can live their lives in peace.
It doesn't seem to balance out the extraordinary
lengths to which Robotnik is willing to go
to stop them.
Part of the issue is that it's unclear what
Dr. Robotnik is even trying to do.
He's lauded by many characters as being a
supergenius, which he'd have to be to invent
all of his machines, but his plan makes very
little sense.
He says he wants to study Sonic, but attempts
to utterly annihilate him at every turn.
Once he learns that Sonic's quills contain
an infinite supply of energy, instead of attempting
to learn how to harness that energy, he throws
even more drones and guns at the problem.
His actions just don't seem to jibe with his
motivations, and while the film waves this
inconsistency away with a simple "he's crazy,"
it comes across as one of the weaker aspects
of a mostly competent plot.
It's been a long time since audiences have
gotten to see Jim Carrey in full-on rubber-face
mode, twisting his expressions and his body
into the cartoonishly silly permutations that
made him one of the biggest stars in the world
in the mid-'90s.
Following his Ace Ventura and Dumb and Dumber
days, Carrey took on a series of more serious
roles in films like The Truman Show and Eternal
Sunshine of the Spotless Mind, which still
played to Carrey's comedic sensibilities,
but in much subtler ways.
Now, Carrey is back with a vengeance, bringing
every bit of his bizarre '90s energy to the
character of Dr. Robotnik, who chews through
scenery like a woodchipper and delivers every
line cranked up to eleven.
"Are you in charge here?"
"Yes I--"
"NOPE.
WRONG.
I'M IN CHARGE.
ME.
I'm in charge."
For fans nostalgic for Carrey's most famous
roles, it's like climbing into a time machine.
Watching him in Sonic the Hedgehog, it's hard
to believe that it's been more than a quarter
of a century since Ace Ventura, as Carrey
channels the much younger version of himself
with ease.
In one particularly delightful scene, Robotnikv
dances as he works in his lab, and the whole
sequence just Carrey doing what Carrey does
best, milking the visual medium and his unique
skill set for all they're worth.
“... when you see him do the things that
made you love comedy as a kid and see him
like reinventing that and playing with that
again.
It's just incredibly exciting."
For all of Carrey's comedic strengths, his
performance winds up being somewhat out of
sync with the rest of the movie.
Carrey's over-the-top comedy doesn't entirely
gel with the easy banter between Tom and Sonic,
and his exaggerated physicality feels at odds
with the grounded nature of the other human
characters.
Granted, Carrey's entire brand in the '90s
was built around being an energetic, flamboyant
weirdo in a sea of everymen, and that's definitely
what he's doing here as well.
But that sort of character feels almost out
of place in Sonic, as though Dr. Robotnik's
plot -- even though it helps drive the main
conflict of the movie -- was just stapled
on from a totally different film.
The problem may be that Carrey's playing a
villain here, not the protagonist.
The movie isn't built around him, and as such,
it doesn't accommodate his overwhelming presence
nearly as neatly as his starring vehicles
have.
It worked for a different villainous role,
when Carrey played the Riddler in 1995's Batman
Forever, but Sonic lacks the wacky, neon energy
that helped Carrey's performance slot neatly
into the Batman world.
Here, although Carrey is undeniably a master
of his craft, he winds up straining the seams
of the film.
To put it simply, Carrey is great, but he
may just be too much for Sonic the Hedgehog.
"OHHHHHHH.
Give me a big!
Fat!
Break!"
The character of Sonic may be best known for
his speed, but when it comes to the story
of Sonic the Hedgehog, the film has a firm
grasp on what's actually most important to
the little blue guy, and it's not how fast
he can run.
Early on in the film, after watching a group
of kids congratulate one another after a Little
League baseball game, Sonic plays a game of
baseball by himself.
Using his speed, he can play every position
all at once, but after an entertaining sequence
of Sonic running the bases, he holds up his
hand for a high five and… no one's there.
The speedster sequences in Sonic are a lot
of fun, but where the film really finds its
heart is in its exploration of Sonic's isolation.
While Sonic lies to himself, pretending that
the imaginary friendships he's made up with
the people of Green Hills are enough to sustain
him, it's clear that he longs for connection
with someone outside of himself, someone who
knows and cares that he's there.
After the final showdown with Robotnik, Sonic
finally gets a real high five from Tom, which
feels far more satisfying than Sonic's triumph
over Robotnik.
Ultimately, the film closes with Tom and Maddie
making Sonic his own "cave" in their house,
making him part of the family and proving
with their actions that finally, Sonic has
a place where he truly belongs.
Although Sonic's ending with the Wachowskis
is nothing short of perfect, the rest of the
film's odd plot doesn't wrap up nearly so
neatly.
Early on in Sonic the Hedgehog, Pentagon officials
meet to investigate the mysterious blackout
that Sonic caused in Green Hills, and decide
to hire Dr. Robotnik to look into it, since
he's the smartest person they know.
As events progress, the government frames
Tom as a terrorist, plastering his photo across
every major news network along with headlines
that label him a wanted fugitive.
Ultimately, Sonic and Tom wind up sending
Robotnik through a portal to the mushroom
planet, wiping the government's asset off
the face of the earth.
Yet at the end of the film, Tom is back at
home, still talking about his career in law
enforcement, and completely unconcerned that
anyone might be looking for him.
When Commander Walters knocks on his door,
it isn't to arrest Tom or even to reprimand
him, but to thank Tom and Maddie for their
discretion, and give them… a $50 gift card
to Olive Garden?
Sure, paying off Tom's Olive Garden comment
from the beginning of the film is worth a
chuckle, but it's at the expense of all logic.
Shouldn't the government be concerned about
what happened to Robotnik?
Shouldn't they be wanting to pin all the damage
that occurred on Tom, who they already painted
as a terrorist?
Do they just not care about the blackout anymore?
While it's great that Sonic, Tom, and Maddie
get to live happily ever after -- at least
until the sequel -- it's hard to overlook
just how little sense it makes.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.